what do you think which of these  paintings was painted by a famous artist  so the right answer is that the top  picture is painted by a person this  painting is called forgetting numbers by  artist Eve tongi and this painting was  created by the neural network [ __ ]  some animators are readily using these  modern Technologies to create animated  films for example the author of the more  underscore teza Channel created a short  film Seasons using several artificial  intelligence platforms it turned out  pretty well right however in some places  it's a little rough around the edges the  work of the neural network is still  noticeable however other artists flat  out refused to turn towards AI for  example when the world famous Hayao  Miyazaki was shown a zombie created by  AI he had some harsh words to say about  the neural network right in front of its  creators  so what do you think are machines  capable of replacing animators and  artists subscribe to some sub